The strength i can starting it
and i mean by watching a lot of these
kind of derelicts and and people like
that in the street
and especially there's one guy called
tree who i'm sure you'll hear about time
and time again and.
He would sit in the street and
sort of try and beg from people
and just talk to himself.
This is actually quite insane and the
money that is to get from his daltex
and from begging from people he would
line up in rows of sort of one
and to think lines or ten
cent pieces in the street
and he would count his way along them.
And and work out whether he was actually
going to have enough to buy a flag and
that day and he would kind of put a
marker further up in the street.
I mean the watch him do it quite clearly
he put a marker a piece of wood.
Where his coins would have to get to in
order for him to be able to afford this
flag and i just thought well this
really is a desperate situation isn't.
I mean i had you know $2 50
and i've hock it myself to go
and buy lollies whether you
know that wasn't a problem
but this guy just didn't
have a under control
and i'm there are a lot of people
like that who are kind of sit
and have really slow kind of.
Meaningless arguments in the street and
they would never raise their voices
or actually get animated or anything
like that they would just sit there
and argue it out all day and get
really in-depth about everything.
And then i rember other people who just
kind of sit there with their guitar
or with their bongos and not play
them for hours and you know you
and so you walk past some really hairy guy
you sitting there looking at his guitar
and he hasn't worked out yet.
You know that he's he's not
playing or that he can't play it.
You know just keep you
know just keep going
and i don't know if i remember the way
you know when people see every stone
and sort of dance around and
they were getting right into it
and feeling really good about everything
and kind of you know makes everyone
feel a little bit uncomfortable.
These people are doing this because it's
there's something really lost about it
and you know.
Remember a lot of sort of messy situations
where people would would fight about
money or about something
like that and then
and i would see another person
come in and settle it all down
and like see see people being
treated like children all the time
and that's really funny thing because you
know it's like in all communities where
whenever things blow up there are
always people are step in and try
and sort them out and so the
same nimbin when you know
when the situation on the street got
out of hand people would step in
and diffuse it all and sort
of pat everyone on the back
and say you know it's ok you don't
have to worry about it and you know.
As often as not these situations would
just sort of die down straight away.
And i mean you know people probably have
an image of the place as being very kind
of nasty and violent and i
really dark side to all of that
but it is have to remember that it's
people trying to get on with their thing
and that those situations can you know
can actually be resolved as well.
Yeah and i mean.
I don't know the other thing is like even
all of those families like ours that
when i moved out there and lived in a
half built tent or something like that.
You know we always had
sort of food and beds
and our own sort of domestic
situation sorted out you know
and there's this whole
other group of people
that i haven't really talked about yet the
kind of feral people who have chosen to
live a completely kind of feral existence
up in the bushes with no kind of you know
civilized housing or any
of that type of thing
and then they get really really dirty
and they live in a really really primitive
way and it's funny because i know
that they're living in a primitive way and
that they're not sort of you know having
any kind of western you know material
things around them or anything
like that but then again.
They're doing it as a reaction
to the western way of living
and so what they're doing is kind of like
anti-western living as opposed to just a
natural instinct to feral way of living
which say indigenous people would do
and it's really funny to see the lengths
that they have to go to in order to
maintain a kind of really simple.
All and and unconscious type
of lifestyle and you know
that the whole thing about you
know having a car for example
and one of them always have a car because
eventually they're going to have to go
somewhere and and you know but
they like to sort of pretend
that they don't have a car
and they don't need any of
that type of stuff coming here. And.
And so you've got these kind of groups of
people making a massive effort to live in
a really kind of simple way and going
out of their way to do it continuously
and in my whole life i've never actually
stopped to think why they were doing it
because like there are some things like
pornography and you know advertising
and things like that which i really
dislike about our consumeristic society.
But then there you know all of the rest of
it seems quite acceptable to me whether
you take it on as a really serious type
of thing whether you just do it without
thinking about it and so i don't see
what actually requires that effort.
So the roses.
Well you know there's that.
Yeah there's also the dilemma that
they are trying to be self-sufficient.
But in the end they're going to
need to get some money somehow.
And so they can rely on society
to support them or they can try
and produce something
that's all value. Ok.
And when they you know
when they produce those things like
the things they sell at the markets
and stuff like that they try
and do in the most organic kind of
you know down to earth possible way
but they're still relying on a very kind
of you know western society approach to
doing the whole thing in
order to make it work.
And so you know even though they they
are living alternative lifestyles.
They should you know be
careful to acknowledge
that they're still kind of participating
in our mainstream society and
that it's still sort of you know tourists
and those kind of people who
are buying their things
and supporting their lifestyle.
You know as removed
and as simple as they think they might be.
Oh yeah well there was this guy who was
there was this guy who was there before.
All i arrived. Who was convinced that
aliens when we're going to come down
and sort of you know
save the whole planet.
And it was going to happen on this
particular night in this particular place
and you took a whole lot of people
there and they stayed up or mine
and watched a couple of
satellites going overhead
and we're almost convinced at one stage
but no then it all kind of fell down.
I mean it was one of those classic things
where the actual event didn't take place
but the purpose of the event.
You know was just as powerful anyway because
all these people were actually brought
together by it and you know and
something started through and
that was out of my line bimby
and you know they ended up starting
some really good communes out there
and you know he was a
big part of all of that
but just you know a lot of those kind
of trippers who make everyone stop
and listen to their story about whether
it's aliens or about armageddon
or whatever you know have all got this
sort of thing in common with all they want
is for everyone to gather around
and listen to their story.
But the actual contents of the story
are usually completely meaningless
or you know completely nonsense.
Yeah.
I'm putting forward to you my my
proposition that it's the police
that are largely responsible
for the overwhelming
presence of the hard drug scene in
nimbin at the moment i mean i believe
that it's just there are too many of them.
I mean there's bound to be a small number
of people using narcotics in any culture
at the moment in australia
and particularly in a culture where the
other drugs are such an integral part of
the community but the policing
is the problem at neiman
and i think the policing the reason
that the police won't police
nimbin is a very simple one
and it relates to their envy.
Envy is a is a very basic human feeling
like anger and avarice and sloth
and the other seven dead. These
since. Envy is ubiquitous.
I personally feel that it was envy
that was the problem on our commune that
made it impossible for us to share.
I think it was not possible for some of
the other people not to envy the way i
could easily make money
and at this distorted in all sorts
of complicated ways the things
that was going down. But i think the envy
that the police feel for those of us
that nimbin is very very deep and very
very profound for the first few years
when i had this wonderful relationship
with the one policeman in town.
I think that the situation
was very very different
but then he actually left the town because
he couldn't cope with just how ambiguous
and complicated it was he was a
lovely guy but he said himself.
I can't go on with this
amount of ambiguity
and i know i my kids to be growing up in
a drug town like this. I've got to go.
And from then on we had a succession
of policemen and policewomen.
In various numbers coming
there who i think.
Really hated name and they hate and
envy people like me they hate.
And to some extent envy
people who are on the dole
and who can grow enough
to run a car on the dole
and live a pretty comfortable
lifestyle not a wonderful lifestyle
but the lifestyle of the average
policeman with a mortgage
and all of those things is not
all that bloody comfortable.
So the sight of a bunch of people
on the dole still driving a car.
And never working the bunch of a
the sight of people like me who
can cross the boundaries between
the professional groupings.
And and the tribe out there and
live a comfortable lifestyle
and maybe even drive a sports car.
I think that the police are
tremendously envious of.
Most of the aspects of
the nimbin phenomenon.
Therefore.
They will not do what they
would do in any other place
when it comes to crime. I
think they rather feel it.
We should do you in our own shit.
Firstly they can always justify their
inactivity with respect to the hard drugs by
saying are you. But you just want
us to bust the narcotics people
and a lay off you doped smokers
and of course that's not what
a policeman espouse to do so.
All right will lay off the dope smokers
but don't you expect us
then to be discriminating.
That's not what a policeman is supposed to
do so they have a rational a rationale a
rationalization for going easy
on the more obvious narcotic.
Dealing and using that goes on in
town but that's just the rationale.
What's behind it is they hate
that place. They hate the end.
They've always hated the
intelligentsia. They hate the artists.
I mean that's not what a
policeman is about policemen
and not about the finer things in life
policemen by choice actually come into
contact with some of the most disastrous
human beings in the community
and i've got a vile job and i'm not
saying that they're envy is unique.
I've just said that envy i think
fucked up my community but i think
that in this particular case
it is the envy of the police
that forces them into a particular
level of inactivity which then ensures
that we have a very special
drug problem in them.
They will not police that town and
i will not walk around that town.
The police department will
not put on. And after.
For them to just walk around
the town. There's a certain.
Sort of overt drug use which
just couldn't happen if there
was a policeman walking by gleason doesn't
have to even do anything he just has to
be there or she has to be there. They
won't do that in them they just won't.
And i say well that's because we'd
have to book the dope smokers
but that's not the case.
Well firstly they wouldn't have to they
could actually be discriminating policemen
of discriminating all the time they
don't bust each other for speeding.
So we're up against it in him and.
With the fact
that the police are not giving us a fair
deal about hard drug users just not
policing it. And that's because
they want us to steer our own shit.
Whatever you know.
Well i still don't think they can do
it without the police cooperation.
Yes it is true
that we've never been able to draw lines
although i've never been able to draw
lines in nimbin. And you know that.
They have always been in difficulty in
finally deciding that x is gone too far.
Unless it's. That x has gone too far
in a fir to some sort of leadership.
If effects begins to assert something
that might be interpreted as leadership
they've got the shit kicked out of the
mediately
but if you go too far with respect to
sitting in the middle of the main street
or anything like that it would be very
hard for newman to draw the line.
So yes obviously enough. There's
a potential for for. Serious.
A legal drug users too.
To parade themselves in nimbin without
getting the usual public condemnation
that might keep them in
order but i don't think
that we could do anything in nimbin about
that problem unless the
police actually came clean
and the police are playing it very dirty
in the embed and they always have.
Yes.
We.
Yeah now i'm not i'm not
happy about the way
that continues to be a
feature of name and life.
It is the i mean it's a
movie again. Yeah yeah.
I feel that the way in
which leadership is.
Dissolved dispersed denied in name is
another real example of just what a
very very important part in human affairs
in the play is of course once again
there is a rationale for it in nimbin
you know if everybody's to be free
and autonomous and and where
to have a real anarchy then.
Obviously enough no one should leave
because they would have to impose their
particular style on other
people and. That is you know.
Then the false rationales
for tearing down leaders.
It's in it's in the interests
of anarchy and real autonomy
that we have to get rid of the sorts
of people who want to be leaders
but i've already said that i
think that that's a disaster.
And that's not right but i also
believe that the tearing down of.
Leaders is. You know the
prime the cardinal example.
Of australia's.
Endemic of a stray liens
endemic envy which is
that which runs very deep in all stray
liens may have something to do with our
convict background or something but
i think it is it's a bad thing.
It would be wonderful
if we could overcome.
And we will won't overcome it until we
acknowledge just how many areas of life.
Of our own personal lives
and of our larger lives as a community
until we acknowledge how deeply envy
pervades our community.
So paul newman has not managed
to transient the problem that.
You know. I think bedevils
all of australia.
With respect to the tall poppy syndrome
nim and hasn't transcended that
and simply because you know nimbin
have interpreted anarchy and
and freedom as meaning there would not
be and they would not need to be leaders
and i of course believe that
that's complete nonsense i think
that we have to have inspirational
human beings around us in order to
be inspired
and in order to radiate light ourselves
we need to be exposed to radiant
beings.
There have been a lot of people at nimbin
who are pretty radiant sort of creatures
and they do get a pretty rough time.
Yeah well. Yes yes.
Meetings have been a feature of nimbin
and they have taken the same form.
You know from day one where.
Anybody who attempted to take a
real leadership role as. Has come.
Has come adrift and where everybody
you know has the right to be heard
and there's some aspect of that which
i really appreciate i think that.
I'm. Actually i'm i.
I'm not a member of the quakers
but i am a quaker i'm a regular attender
at quaker meetings and you may know
that quite as were the first
group of people to enshrine
consensus as the most appropriate
way of decision making.
Well i really do appreciate
the fact that it and him
and there is an attempt always to to
find some sort of consensus in meeting.
Now of course just as with the
quakers i mean you will notice
that you don't know many quakers
they're not a very evangelical bunch
and they're very quiet and very low profile
and usually very beautiful people.
But it certainly isn't a movement
that's taken over the world and
that is undoubtedly.
A consequence of their commitment to
this fascinating process of consensus
and that's what everybody tries for
at all of the meetings in nimbin
and just as the quakers will
never take over the world.
There's no doubt
that what it is that's happening at neiman
will never take over the world because
of their commitment to
everybody being heard
and particularly everybody trying to.
You know to come from their higher self
in their communications with other people
but it does mean that you have
to listen to some arseholes.
And that certainly you know
bogs down the process.
My pleasure and privilege.